مسلسلات بريكنج باد وصراع العروش تعتبر
الافضل في التاريخ وفقا لتقييمات
المشاهدين ومعظم النقاط اما في النصف
الثاني من الكوكب هجوم العمالقه العمل
الياباني الذي اذيعت اولى حلقاته قبل عشره
اعوام هو العمل الاسطوري في عالم الانمي
شخصيات هجوم العمالقه او اتاك اون تايتن
مكتوبه بدقه شديده وبطل الحكايه وحتى الى
الادوار الثانويه لدرجه ان شخصيه تظهر في
حلقه او حلقتين قبل ان تموت تفرض نفسها
وتترك اثرا في قلوب الجمهور القصه مستمره
في الموسم الرابع والاخير الذي ينقسم
لثلاثه اجزاء والحلقه الاولى من اخر جزء
والتي صدرت خلال الاسبوع الجاري خلق الضجه
عالميه كالعاده وتعرض حصريا على منصه شاهد
الجزء الثالث من الموسم الرابع مقسم ايضا
على نصفين ونصف الثاني يعرض في خريف 2023
قبل ان يرسل الستار على احد اهم اعمال
الانمي على الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
هجوم العمالقه الاعلى تقييما على مستوى
اعمال الانمي يدور حول كفاح البشريه ضد
العمالقه للبقاء على قيد الحياه فكره
بسيطه لكن خلفها عشرات الحكايات والكثير
جدا من المشاعر في الاصل كان من المفترض
ان يكون ايرينجر بطل القصه عملاقا طوال
الوقت لكن هجيمي ايسياما كاتب المانجا
تراجع عن الفكره اما ميكاسا فهي اول شخصيه
قام بابتكارها خطط الكاتب ايضا ان ينهي
المانجا نهايه الماساويه حيث تموت كل
الشخصيات لكن التقييمات الايجابيه
والمتابعه الكبيره للعمل دفعته لتغيير
الاحداث بسبب تعلق المعجبين بالابطال قصص
المانجا بدات قبل سبع سنوات تقريبا من عرض
الانمي لاول مره وحاليا يتكلف انتاج
الحلقه الواحده 300 الف دولار واخيرا
بعد نجاح اتاك اون تيتان كان هجيبي
ايسياما اغنى كاتب مانجا عام 2021
وتكسر ثروته اليوم حاجزه الخمسه واربعين
مليون دولار
ينضم الينا من الاحسان محمد النعامي
المختص في اخبار الانمي اهلا بك محمد معنا
في صباح العربيه ثلث الاخير من هذه
الملحمه العالميه هجوم العالم عمالقه كيف
كانت الاصداء فور نزول الحلقه الاولى
اهلا وسهلا
لا ينفك العمل هذا عن مفاجاتنا باصدع
الاصداء كانت قويه جدا للجمهور متحمس
مع استكمال البارتات من السلسله هذه عقد
اصداء يعني جباره جدا في العالم
طيب محمد يعني عشان احنا نفهم اليوم بعد
عشر سنين من هذا العمل ليه تم انتاج الجزء
الثالث من الموسم الرابع وبقسمين يعني
القسم الاول بحلقه واحده وساعه كامله
تقريبا
وتتكون في خليفه هذا العام يعني كيف راح
نفهم هلا المتوقع يعني ساعه اخرى كامله
انه شو السبب من هذا النوع من العرض
والتاخير مثلا
والله يعني
العراق متضاربه ما بين انها اولا التجاره
يعني الارباح اللي ممكن تحققها العمل
الانتاج العالي للعمل هذا ايضا هو سبب اخر
يعني
الارباح فعلا حققها لكن الانتاج اللي
يتطلب اهل العمل هذا كبير يعني لما نشوف
البوت هذا الصوتيات اللي وضعت فيه الاخراج
الكم اللي وضع فيه من
الفوادر يوضح انه فعلا انه صعب
انتاج العمل هذا في حلقه او حلقتين او
ثلاث فهم كانت لهم فكره معينه واعتقد انهم
وصلوا لها سواء كان ربحيا او تشويقيا او
انتاجيا طيب موسم واحد استمر انتاجه لاكثر
من عامين وتقسيمه الى اجزاء طيب ما هي
الاستراتيجيه الحقيقيه برايك وراء هذا
التشويق الطويل
وداعيه اي عمل
او الانتاج الاخير من اي عمل يكون عاده
بتخوف كبير تخوف كبير من التفت كيفيه طرح
القصه تخوف كبير من كيفيه الناس يعني هل
سيكون في تقبل من الناس لنهايه العمل هذا
او لا اعمال كثيره كان العمل الجزء الاخير
منها وهو ممكن نقول الاسوء تقييما لان
الناس مو متقبله للفراق هذا ومش متقابله
للجزء الاخير
الزخم اللي عملها الاستديو في التسويق
الموسم الاخير فعلا قاعد يرتقي يرتقي اكثر
واكثر واكثر واكثر حتى تقييما فواقع يرتقي
طب يا استاذ محمد
اليوم ان نقول وداعا لانمي ضخم واسطوري
يعني ليس بالامر المعتاد في الانتاجات
اليابانيه اليوم ماذا يدور من احاديث وسط
عشاق الانمي وصناعه يعني هل من المعقول ان
يغادرنا هذا العمل الذي كبرنا عليه
ومازلنا نعشقه حتى لو صرنا كبارا
نعم
الساعه راح اكون النهايه لكن الذكاء اللي
قاعدين يسوونه ان المشهد الاول من الحلقه
هذه اللي نزلت تخ عن روايه او المانجا
للعمل لدوله الكليه اعتقد انه ممكن يتم
تغيير القصه او ممكن يتم اضافه شيء لان في
مشهد مثلا زي السياره مشهد الطفل المشهد
حديث ميكاسا في البدايه هذا مختلف تماما
عن اللي جاء في القصه او جاء في المانجا
مميتيح مجال هل راح نشوف نهايه مختلفه
مثلا كيف راح تكون الوداعيه ليش تم اقتحام
الصوره هذه المختلفه لميكاسا هذا هذه
الاشياء تخلي حتى اللي شاف المانجا يتساءل
ايش راح يتم في الحلقه القادمه او في
الساعه القادمه وليش التقسيم بهذه الطريقه
يعني صراحه ذكاء انتاجي غير طبيعي انا
قاعد اشوفه من الاستديو شكرا جزيلا لك من
الحساب محمد النعامي المختص في اخبار
الانمي